hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and we finally
have confirmation of the demon slayer
season 2 release date up until this
point we all knew that it would be
coming sometime in 2021 and while many
of us were speculating that it would
likely start airing in october of 2021
we didn't know for sure i mean it would
make sense since october is the start of
a new fall anime season but then again
if we look at last year attack on titan
started airing in december so you never
know however we now finally have the
information for demon slayer season 2
and i am so excited because season 2 is
going to cover what is probably my
favorite arc in the whole story so let's
get into it if you enjoyed the demon
slayer content on this channel and you
want us to keep it going just leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps with the youtube
algorithm and if you're new to anime pro
or maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications okay so the official
japanese demon slayer website recently
stated that demon slayer season 2 will
air on fuji tv in japan every sunday in
october of 2021 that's every sunday in
quotation marks both crunchyroll news
and the anime news network are also
reporting this and it has been reported
that demon slayer season 2 will feature
two coors meaning that it will have at
least 25 or 26 episodes and that it will
air during both the fall and winter
anime seasons this is amazing news
obviously since it means that we're
gonna get the same amount of episodes as
we had in season one and this means that
we won't get like a reduced 12 episode
or 13 episode half season many big anime
like attack on titan had these reduced
12 or 13 episode seasons in the past and
i know that some people were definitely
afraid that this could happen to demon
slayer as well thankfully that is not
gonna be the case we're gonna be getting
the full 25 or 26 episodes and they're
going to be airing in the fall of 2021
and winter of 2022. now the big question
is this we know that demons player
season 2 is going to be airing on
sundays in october but which exact
sunday in october will the first episode
air the very first sunday in october is
october 3rd right at the beginning of
the month so it is fair to assume that
demon slayer season 2 could also begin
airing as soon as october 3rd which is
only about 3 weeks after the making of
this video that's actually crazy that's
really soon and i definitely hope that
this is the case since i can't wait for
this season to begin as i said earlier
it is covering one of my absolute
favorite arcs in the whole story the red
light district arc also known as the
entertainment district arc and i will
talk more about the ark in a second but
first i do want to mention that while it
definitely makes sense for demon slayer
to start airing on the very first sunday
of october since the news websites are
reporting that it will air every sunday
in october and that of course includes
the first sunday october 3rd it is still
possible that the season might begin
airing on a different sunday in october
obviously i wanted to start right away
on the 3rd but we can't exclude the
possibility that it might start like a
week later on the 10th so while i am
hopeful that we're gonna get it started
as soon as possible i do want to give
everyone a heads up that the anime
production schedules in japan can be
weird and unpredictable at times now on
top of this massive release date news we
also have some other interesting news
relating to the demon slayer anime the
anime news network is reporting that
fuji tv the tv station that is going to
be airing season 2 in october is also
going to be airing five special
compilations of demonstrators season 1
in september these compilations will
serve as a recap of season 1 for
everyone who wants to refresh their
memories before heading into season 2.
but interestingly enough these
compilations are said to feature new
footage that wasn't originally included
with the first season that is actually
really interesting and i'm curious to
see what new footage they're talking
about will this be manga content that
the anime didn't include or will it be
stuff that wasn't even in the manga
these five specials or recap
compilations will air on september 11th
12th 18th 19th and the 23rd and if we
get something interesting in that
special extra footage i will of course
let you guys know right here on the
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
click the bell so you don't miss any
latest demon slayer updates now let's
talk about season 2 itself and the first
arc that it is going to cover the red
light district arc also known as the
entertainment district arc if you've
heard the arc called the red light
district and entertainment district and
you're confused don't worry this is the
same arc i think that the words red
light district have certain connotations
that some publications would prefer to
avoid and that is why they refer to it
as the entertainment district arc
this arc takes place four months after
the events of the mugen train arc our
boys tanjiro zenitsu and inosuke have
been training hard to get stronger and
they've also been going on demon slayer
missions to gain experience
following some sudden and strange events
that nearly led to aoi being kidnapped
tanjiro zenitsu and inosuke are
recruited for an important mission by
tengen uzui a former ninja and current
sound hashira uzui is a flashy and
flamboyant gigachad and one of my
favorite characters in the entire story
he informs tanjiro and the gang that
they are going to be heading into the
flashiest place in all of japan a place
full of lost and avarice the red light
district apparently this district has
been plagued by demon activity and a lot
of people have gone missing there
recently these disappearances are likely
the result of demon attacks but whoever
these demons are they've been extremely
effective in avoiding detection now
remember when i said that uzui was a
gigachad i really wasn't joking this man
is such a chad that he actually has not
one but three hot ninja wives and these
three wives infiltrated the red light
district in order to gather intel and
locate the elusive demon who has been
hiding there however their secret
communications with uzui suddenly
stopped that is why uzui needs backup
and our heroes tanjiro inosuke and
zenitsu disguise themselves as girls in
order to infiltrate three establishments
within the red light district
establishments which have been
identified by uzui as the most likely
hiding places of the demon or demons
this incredibly unique situation leads
to tons of both comedy and drama and the
entire arc is just a masterpiece in my
opinion the main villain of this arc is
also absolutely exceptional it is
somewhat powerful devious and absolutely
full of surprises i can't wait to see
this entire arc animated and if you've
been enjoying the demon slayer anime so
far trust me when i say that it is only
going to get better from here let me
know down in the comments if you're
excited for season 2 of demon slayer and
what is your personal favorite arc in
the story if you only seen the anime
then you can just pick one from the
anime movie and if you read the manga
then you can also include the manga arcs
i look forward to hearing from you down
in the comments if you enjoyed this
demon slayer video and you want us to
keep it going definitely leave a like it
only takes a second but it helps a lot
and if you don't want to miss any future
demon slayer videos or important updates
definitely don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you have to make sure
that you subscribe hit the bell and then
also select that option that says all if
you don't do that you're still going to
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror i want to give a
quick thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons who make videos like this
one possible special thank you to alpha
sigma he is an absolute mad lad and
disciple of lord twego himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrata pate heffa
algital hinokamien water the toasted chi
the spike dylan isidore spidey life
chanel tungsten tarcus big buddhist and
monkey d quilly finally thank you to all
of our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh the red
haired raven angel crews rathune de ora
very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
joanne garcia ted no ted fatboy games
corey mcgowan and soul ray slice and
dice if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value to you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patreon exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these legendary people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you